welcome to this new video groundhog day
it's the opponent from oh yeah now call
it sit Australia is it New Zealand yeah
okay now I know I knew it was close it's
one of those ok we have them I o'kelly's
this all your child with c3 and now we
transpose to something that looks a lot
like em um in advanced french let's see
this ideas to play Bishop b5 at some
point in fact that i played it like
immediately and i hope that this wasn't
the best timing because now the b5 porn
needs some attention I thought it was
would be more precise to maybe take on
d4 first hoping for the sea pawn we
captured then brief Bishop b5 this now
looks a bit oh really
giving away this bishop hmm now that's a
very uncommon decision
mm yes let's let's castle first um
hmm
I wonder I cannot really move the bishop
anyway I wonder if maybe I should just
go queen e 2 and add 90 form how does he
protect me five don't really see how
soon
wait if I take take now on c5 I Scott c4
for the Queen takes Bishop b3 and the
Queen only has got c4 but ok c4s not a
bad square maybe maybe this is in fact a
good idea ree routing the night to d3
just attacking the bishop twice and ask
him him there to where to put it oh wait
why do you put it now
in the bishop's trapped yep Queen f3 on
Queen f3s got 95
isn't this thing just trapped
yeah it is trapped just with this I
guess so let's just recap sure this way
so the easiest just a piece now ok
yes don't need to be an precise he's got
them a bit of a temporary activity night
here group here the rookie especially as
some is an annoying piece should I play
g3 here prevent anything going to h4
that no maybe yeah this I thought Queen
f3 would be good because the rock now
assam is basically trapped can oh you
can only play awkward moves like this so
now I'm threatening Bishop t6
I can play five nights our kids not
great f5
everything else fails on f5 I can just
take
I don't really see an alternative to Eve
f5 cannot really play something else I
don't I don't see another move I was f5
not working ahead as well yeah I
probably am there isn't a good way to
continue here I thought I'd just take to
keep it simple and now play normal move
Luke c1 or something this piece has
tests no square and this this just
activates all my pieces yeah he ignored
this 93 idea trapping trapping the the
bishop yeah this just this was just
played the plate too quickly it looks
nicer ok for it's a good idea from a
strategical point of view activating the
piece but 93 is the big concrete threat
I thought just this move something like
this and then it continues not sure the
compounds played reform it's probably
not bad evil but this the pieces are a
nicely placed they continue they control
a good good squares and this is may be
interesting something like this the
computer recommendation it looks nice I
have got good control here but it's not
it's not a fatal position for black or
anything you can just play this in the
game after this it's truly a piece can
only can't try to stay up some trouble
but it's some precise movements
efficient rookie one is better huh
computer move but g3 it doesn't really
matter it's it's just a piece yeah
thanks for watching